thank you kirstama's here um your
thoughts after yesterday
well
uh we only had part of the story from
sue grey obviously but it was a pretty
damning part of the story we know that
of the 12 parties or gatherings that she
was investigating of the 16 she was
investigating 12 of them are going to
the police for investigation because the
police have assessed that they're
serious enough and flagrant enough
to put on one side the usual rule that
they won't look at things more than 12
months ago so it's as damning as it
could be and
you know we're all paying the price for
the chaos and incompetence and worse of
the prime minister and his behavior and
now we need to wait
for the police report we've got to wait
for the police to investigate so we've
got a prime minister who
i think broke the rules
i think then lied about breaking the
rules who then instigated the sue grey
report and has now brought a criminal
investigation upon himself
and that is about as damning as it can
get for a british prime minister of
whatever political party
meanwhile meanwhile
people are seeing their energy bills go
up but nothing is being done about it
and so
you know there was a real range of
emotions yesterday in the house because
i think the one thing that the last six
seven weeks
of allegations about the prime
minister's behaviour has done is forced
everybody to relive
moments in their own lives in the last
two years those were dark moments and
people have felt
angry
they felt grief and
and they felt guilt and i've had so many
people say to me here i feel guilty
because i followed the rules
i didn't do what i wanted to do in my
heart go and look after my dad clean up
look after an elderly relative and i've
i feel guilty that i didn't do it
because i was obeying the rules and
people feel that they've been taken for
mugs
there's now a further emotion which is
frustration which is why energy bills
are going up and the government's doing
absolutely nothing about it
now we the labour party have said we'll
cut those energy bills we set out how we
would fund that with a windfall tax on
oil and gas
we want the government to get on with it
we've got a motion this afternoon in
parliament to be voted on
but the prime minister is spending all
of his time saving his own skin instead
of running the country isn't he a lawyer
i mean given that you are a lawyer he
certainly isn't um isn't he innocent
until proven guilty
well of course he is but um
judging him
we got to an absurd situation yesterday
where he was asked a very simple
question
were you at the party in your own flat
on the 30th of november 2020
and he says i can't answer that because
there's police investigation that is
nonsense when that president is the
police investigation how does it
prejudice the police investigation for
him to admit that he was at a party in
his own flat i'm sorry that is bordering
on the ridiculous because he could have
gone through that he lives there he
could be in one of the bedrooms there
could be something going on elsewhere
and he wouldn't even know about it you
know a bit like when he went into the
garden he didn't know that that was the
gathering and when he knew then he left
and he didn't know he was totally
ambushed by the cake he didn't know that
that was going to be a birthday yeah
apparently he went into the garden and
there were bottles of wine and trellises
of of sandwiches and lots of people
drinking and he didn't realize
it was a party until he was 20. he was
trying to run the country at the time we
were in the middle of a pandemic do you
know one of things that has angered
people most over the last few weeks is
one they know he broke the rules
two they think he's insulting their
intelligence with these ridiculous
defenses and he's also forcing all of
his front benches ministers out onto
your programs and others
to make complete falls of themselves
peddling these absurd defenses isn't
that up to them well it is up to them
but meanwhile we've got an energy bill
crisis which isn't being addressed and
that is why we've had a proposal on the
table to reduce energy bills for um
several weeks now and the government is
doing absolutely nothing about it and
whilst they're trying to save his skin
he was supposed to have a meeting with
the chancellor last week about energy
bills it got cancelled because he needed
to spend his time with his own
backbenchers saving his own job
families therefore are not getting
reduction on their energy bill and
labour has stepped up to say we've got a
plan we've got a costed plan we want to
move it forward whilst you are
mired in this misbehavior we are we are
putting the case for a new britain built
on security prosperity and respect and
we will continue to make that case and i
invite all tory mps this afternoon if
they really want to move this on and
focus on energy bills vote with us this
afternoon to reduce the bills for
millions of families across the country
yeah well as you know if i had a
conservative mp sitting there they'd be
telling me about the vaccine roll out
and be telling me about how well the
economy is doing they'll be telling me
about how well the furlough scheme went
so you know let's let's put that to one
side if we may and talk about
specifically about what people are
concerned about which is the sugray
report and whether that is in enough for
the prime minister to step down the
prime minister says no it's not it does
look as though his backbenchers are
agreeing with them when you looked over
at them yesterday in the house of
commons how did you feel i looked at
their the one thing there aren't many
advantages being the dispatch box but as
you step forward to the dispatch box
all the sort of friendly faces are
behind you and you've got a wall of
of the government faces
their faces were stony they were not
with him they know how serious this is
um
and and i think that they're ashamed of
the prime minister and you can you can
see very well when they're with him and
when they're not with him and you heard
some of what those on his own side said
yesterday about his behavior they know
that
you know successive prime ministers
whether they're you know conservative
whether their labour have honored the
office they've recognized that to lead
this country is an honor
it's not a birthright and and and i
think they're ashamed of this prime
minister okay this is this was the scene
um yesterday he did have um some uh
support some of them stood up um to
speak um in his support and there was a
lot of nodding from the um front benches
as you said i mean
what would you say to the front bench of
the government this morning
they know that this can't this prime
minister cannot be removed unless they
act
um i think he's unfit for office and i
think they should act and remove this
prime minister is not fit for his
responsibilities
and they've got a choice they either do
that or they carry on debasing
themselves and going out into the
studios peddling his absurd defenses
they have to go out
and make the argument that their prime
minister didn't realize he was at a
party with bottles and sandwiches for
half an hour they have to come and sit
on your show and make that argument they
know it's not true they know it's not
credible i think they are debasing
themselves and debasing their office
they are also not getting on with the
job because they're spending the whole
of their time defending a prime minister
who is indefensible okay you talked
about one in sandwiches we need to deal
with this photograph as well of you with
beer and bodies back in durham i think
it was april of 2020
if you
if you were sue gray would you want to
investigate that i've explained this
photograph which actually came out a
couple of days after it was taken so
many times we were in a constituency
office working it was a few days before
the local elections
and we had nothing to eat a takeaway
came and we ate we stopped to eat the
takeaway and then we went back to work
that is the long and the short of it
there is no breach of the rules there
was no party there's nothing to
investigate and you'd be happy for the
police to look into that in more detail
well look the
police are now looking at 12 of the 16
allegations having assessed them to be
serious there is no breach of the rule
there yeah
so you will be happy absolutely nothing
to hide at all i've explained it so many
times even the prime minister has now
backed off attacking so you would be
happy with the police no problem there's
no breach of the rules okay i didn't
understand what the prime minister was
talking about yesterday when he brought
up jimmy savile what's all that about it
is a ridiculous slur peddled by
right-wing trolls
and um
the disgust and this is where i saw the
faces of the conservative mps the
disgust on their faces
that their prime minister
was debasing himself by sinking so low
in the chamber was clear
you know
they knew
that he was going so low with that slur
with that lie um he'd been advised not
to do it because it's obviously not true
but he does it because he doesn't
understand what honesty and integrity
means when i was director of public
prosecutions i i was superintendent by
the attorney general conservative
attorney general so it is as ridiculous
as it gets and and i'm glad that those
tourist mps were disgusted and many of
them expressed that to me discussed at
their prime minister for debasing
himself in the house of commons instead
of acting with the contrition and the
integrity that he should have shown
yesterday he does what he always does
which is to try to drag everybody into
the gutter with him the one thing we
know about this prime minister is
everybody who's ever come into contact
with him
always gets damaged in the process i've
been working in politics for a very long
time first election i ever covered was
1979 when margaret thatcher won um and i
am used to politicians not liking each
other particularly but they always use
the language of diplomacy you you've
decided to put that away now i i'm not
one of these politicians that is so
tribal that i won't reach out and form
partnerships even friendships with
conservative mps many of them i know i
like and i get along with and i think
that is my reputation in parliament but
when i see a prime minister lacking the
basic honesty and integrity uh for the
job of prime minister then i'm sorry
that's a step too far for me whatever
the color whatever the party of that
prime minister does it make you think
you know i don't want to be involved in
politics anymore if we've got this guy
in charge it's not for me
no it makes me even more determined that
we must make sure this prime minister is
gone he's debasing the officer of office
of prime minister he's just got to go
okay um do you think that he should uh
face face-to-face in uh enquiries from
the police
oh well i mean it's up to the police now
how they conduct their investigations um
and they may well need to uh interview
him that's a matter for them and i don't
think i should be telling them how to do
their job in that respect okay how long
do you think it's going to take i hope
not long it's a very simple offense
how many people were there was there a
reasonable excuse so it's not a lot of
evidence though there's 500 pages and
300 photographs a lot of photographs for
a work event but here we are there are a
lot of photographs and um often a
picture tells a thousand uh words so
pages of a thousand words so you know
we'll see what they say okay let me just
ask you before you go um
it was a very challenging time for a lot
of people the pandemic for you in
particular i mean
you found it very difficult as far as
the family was concerned didn't you
i did but we did um and um
you know my wife lost her mum just
before the pandemic and it was a very
very difficult time for her
um and we as a family had our struggles
um and she had her struggles
i prefer not to go into them in great
detail because i always try to protect
the privacy of my family
but one of the reasons that i said
yesterday that every family was marked
by this
is because we as a family were marked by
it what we didn't do because we followed
the rules and the grief
that that brought in and and the guilt
that that brought upon us and do you
regret about him by the rules now given
what you know was potentially happening
at downing street i think millions of
people feel that they
they were mugs people tossed and turned
at night thinking i should have done
that for my family member i should have
gone in and cleaned up i should have
hugged i should have done something in
the situation
but they didn't because they were
following the rules
and certainly there are elements of that
in my own family
i think every family had elements of
that and now they do look back
and feel
you know that they were mugs they
shouldn't they should know they
shouldn't they should feel
pride
pride that what they did probably saved
the lives of people they will never meet
and that is the real story
of our country through this pandemic and
um the great tragedy now as it's stained
by this prime minister and by his
behavior
so kyra i must let you go thank you very
much indeed for joining us we appreciate
you taking this time thank you